your belief is that Bitcoin will replace
Fiat currencies In Our Lifetime
yeah yeah I I at some point you're not
going to want a government controlled
currency because it does what this
happens you get a boom and then you get
a bust and then the FED has to adjust
um you get and the boom and bust is all
determined by some
political candidate who happened to win
and then they just say okay we're going
to spend a bunch of money and then you
get a boom and then all of a sudden you
you get a huge bust because the FED has
to say wait we're going into
inflationary times we got to raise
interest rates and so all of a sudden
you've got a bust
there's some something healthy about a
boom and a bust but I think you will get
you'll get that anyway
uh people will you know be excited about
something and then less excited and
excited again
I'll give you a kind of interesting
example almost every technology goes
through what I call the the is curve I
even branded it the Draper I asked her
it every industry kind of comes up
um and and then gets hyped to the Max
and then that's sort of the dot on the
eye so the cursive i and then it comes
drops down and they say oh god well this
you know I can't
buy anything with my credit card and I
can't do all these things that the
internet has promised I can't do
anything with it and so for years it
sits there languishing but while it's
languishing all these great Engineers
are working really hard and they're
coming up with a great way for us to
experience this internet thing and then
it starts slowly creeping up like an S
and then it explodes for years and then
it flattens out as new technologies come
along and go through their same is curve
so it's like almost like a false start
in the beginning like yeah like there's
hype because people see what it could be
but the work hasn't been done yet so you
got to do the work and then it takes off
that's exactly right so I think the same
things happened with Bitcoin you've uh
you've you've had the the big hype eye
and by the way the S is much higher than
the I I mean you think about you know
the top of the eye had Amazon valued at
maybe
I don't know 100 million dollars
and now it's worth a couple trillion
yeah two trillion something yeah yeah
um
so that's a thousand times higher than
the I was the s
and so people don't even realize how
creative other people are
and they don't realize how big something
like this can become so the internet
transform Communications information
gaming entertainment
media
taxis hotels
and those are all pretty big Industries
they're big they have a big influence
and all that but um Bitcoin has a
potential Bitcoin with a blockchain the
smart contracts the the
uh eventually doused uh have the
potential to transform the biggest
industries in the world
uh that's all of Commerce
Finance uh it doesn't just stop with
currency it's uh
you're going to see major changes in
real estate as companies like property
all of a sudden
um
uh are the place you go for your title
so you probably wouldn't need title
insurance anymore
um insurance is going to go through
major changes and what is government but
a lot of insurance policies and so
um I think government's going to go
through major transformation in fact
I'd say 80 percent of government is
probably insurance it's your health care
insurance your workman's comp your
welfare your unemployment unemployment
insurance the pension security Social
Security all that stuff
um that probably does make up about 80
percent and so all of that
with a Bitcoin economy could be virtual
and various governments could compete
for your service
to provide better service for you uh and
so I've seen a few governments that are
being built up in space or 11 miles
offshore or in free trade zones or
whatever and uh in fact I'm a I'm a
citizen of one of them which one
um oh God I wish I remembered
um he's going to be mad the guy who
created Aragon
has also now created a new government
Luis
um
uh cuente he uh and
and anyway he made me the 187th uh
member of the of the government you were
one of the first uh e-residents of uh I
think uh yeah there was supposed to be
number one okay but I ended up being
number three because they some New York
Times editor got a chance to defer be
first in exchange for a story yeah and
then jervetsen was second because I felt
like okay Steve you were and it's your
grandfather was the Estonian president
I'll give you number two and then I was
number three okay and um and I really
love that by the way that government is
so far ahead of our government in in
digitizing the government what are they
doing uh digitized voting digitize the
whole economy is digitized your parking
is digitized your taxes are digitized
Everything is Everything is online
and it's very efficient and that has
allowed that government to swing above
its uh weight class it uh it looks like
it's uh I think there may be number
three
as a per capita unicorn Creator wow and
a lot of that is based on a government
that encourages sets its people free
and trust trust them and sets them free
yeah when we switch from let's call it a
Fiat based world to a Bitcoin based
World however that happens
um or whenever that happens
is it a peaceful transfer or do you
worry that there's like conflict and and
as we've seen over the centuries and
even thousands of years whenever Global
Reserve currencies change hands and
things like that it usually hasn't been
very peaceful how do you kind of think
through that and
um obviously there's an investment case
for an asset but then there's also like
you have family you're a human right
like there's things that like you don't
want to see suffering in the world bad
things so how do you think this plays
out
it is playing out and I I would argue
that we were all pretty much at peace
while the internet was booming because
that was all about Communications and
being better
um you know doing business with each
other and building a supply chain
throughout the world and everybody was
benefiting from that and that was
unprecedented at how how much more
productive people were during that time
and how many people got brought out of
poverty during that time
and then Bitcoin came along
and the great countries the great
leaders are the ones who have embraced
Bitcoin the weak leaders are the ones
who are saying no we've got to control
things and all of a sudden they use that
as an excuse or whatever to show their
true colors which is I need to control
everybody when you have a control-based
government government they go to war
because it's a single person it's a weak
person
it's somebody who gets everybody to do
exactly what they want them to do and
those people also want the rest of the
world to do what they want to do and
they um and so they'll attack if they're
not doing what they want to do so I'd
argue it's already happening
um I wouldn't be surprised if there were
more Wars happening and then when all
the wars are done
hopefully we'll all serve most of us
will survive or you know vast majority
Will Survive
um that'll be the time when we all kind
of hold hands
the borders start to drop the businesses
start doing doing work across borders
again uh the supply chain reopens up
around the world we don't have to say us
against them
and we're all better off
it it feels like
um most people I think in the Bitcoin uh
Community think that is the end State
and there's questions in terms of how we
get there
um but also there's questions about the
U.S government and are they going to
fully embrace it are they going to tax
it are they going to
um maybe in the most extreme case ban
ownership or whatever
it also feels like maybe we've kind of
de-risked some of the most extreme
reactions right we have politicians who
hold the asset uh we have many
businesses that are publicly traded that
uh use the asset many Wall Street firms
now are playing in it what do you think
is kind of the play if you will for the
US government is it something where that
is a fast-growing sector we're going to
put some taxes here and that'll be good
enough or do you think that there's
other regulations that you worry about
or people should be paying attention to
now again I I say that we
um the the good leaders are pushing
they're trusting people and setting them
free and the bad leaders are trying to
control things and regulate and tax and
whatever else now
I understand taxing because it it aligns
interests
and I think that the U.S government
should understand
that they've just wasted a ton of money
on a 80 000 IRS agents where if they
became a Bitcoin economy
everybody be paying their taxes
automatically